Leticia is with me in Dallas Texas hi
Leticia how are you hi how are you
better than I deserve what's up
awesome I was calling because I have a
very brief question maybe that you can
help me with I am in a marriage that is
unfortunately headed toward divorce
we've been married for 11 years but
nonetheless I my personal self have a
deep desire to become financially in
debt for however life keeps happening
which that's just inevitable but I want
to know how to deal with the debt
snowball and save as well as transition
into a single motherhood with a
six-year-old so what is your personal
income my personal income about $1,500 a
month I have I have old side which you
would call hustle I have multi-level
marketing for a beauty company called
Mary Kay so that's not including that
though how much are you making on Mary
Kay profit top it probably about $300 a
sale maybe how many sales are you making
a month I just started so I've been in
it for about two months and I've my
highest sell was about $800 and so
probably like four to five sales because
I work full-time so I haven't worked the
business of Mary Kay full-time so the
1500 a month is your full-time job 40
hours mm-hmm I paid a great deal in
healthcare too so a lot of that comes
out of my out of my check for my
daughter and I okay
and what were your child support Bay do
you know that I'm not sure unfortunately
my husband is a little bit secretive he
lost the job that he did that paid a
substantial amount here just about Bob
ago so he has a new job but he has been
transitioning money to another account
of his so that I'm not sure it's only
the court would be able to decipher it
do you do you receive will you receive
anything out of the divorce we've been
there for 11 years and so I I really
just want peace and I just want to be
able to take care of our daughter she is
I am her primary source of security yeah
so I mean are you getting any money out
of this divorce other than maybe alimony
and child support
probably yeah we have a home that I
would more than likely suggest suggest
that we sell ok and what will come out
of it
well the home itself is worth about 208
to 210 somewhere near when we purchased
it two years ago so I'm not really sure
what the sell I'm out well you know come
when you click down when you're
purchased it we put down what we had
from our previous home was was about ten
thousand ok so there's not a lot coming
out of this house then no if anything
okay so you're not getting like a
hundred thousand dollars is he got a
401k you're gonna get half of or
something like that right no okay well
you've got a career crisis then mm-hmm
living in Dallas Texas on 1,500 a month
in an unproven and an unproven sales job
and at least your portion of its
unproven I mean if you can start making
1,500 a month doing that that's our
twenty five hundred a month that's a
proven thing but you haven't done that
yeah and I'm not talking about total
dollars of sales I'm talking about
profit in your pocket exactly which is
different you understand okay and so you
got to have 2,500 coming into your
pocket and or you've got to start
looking for some new careers okay
because 1500 a month in Dallas Texas is
starving to death
mm-hmm exactly with one child that's at
the poverty level mm-hmm
so and it sounds like he's going to be a
bear to collect child support from
and/or alimony and you're not getting
any money from me where else so
is all about you creating money now how
much debt do you guys have well I have
about fifteen thousand dollars in credit
card debt that I've accumulated because
of not lack of help so I kind of took it
upon myself to open credit cards for
things that I felt that we eat it like
car troubles I don't have a car note
anymore so anytime something went wrong
with my car would just kind of charge it
you know clothes or things like that
because I don't make that much money
I started hard in cars that I knew
better but just the situation itself hmm
and I I for sure I have actually have a
notebook that I just had what other what
other what other that's other than the
credit cards do you have
this is student loan that I just
recently deferred with how much
ownership how much is owed only 14 so I
roughly have about a total of thirty
thousand in debt
20 a little over twenty nine dollars
okay all right
I hope you figured out that you cannot
use those credit cards ever oh yeah for
anything because there's no way that
there's no good into this story mm-hmm
if you keep using those things every
time you have a problem and you're going
to keep having problems you're going to
get yourself bankrupt I know this sounds
bad but he hasn't we haven't gotten to
the road of fun like divorce yet so
while the mortgage is still being paid
I'm just trying to pay off as much as I
can right now I actually have one credit
card that is on scared those would be
paid off next month
no not missing I'm sorry February the
23rd so I just literally wrote out every
single detail of my finances okay I'm
sorry
starting to get on track then and you're
starting to develop a plan for life
after no house payment and life after no
more no more using credit cards but I
mean what's happened there you know when
a few minutes ago when I was saying
you're gonna struggle with this income
and you gotta do something to get the
income up you remember what I was saying
that
what happened is you're already been
living in that because you're already
spent fifteen thousand more than you had
come in and you didn't spend it on a
vacation you spent it on life right and
you you were not irresponsible in terms
of what you bought
you're just irresponsible on how you
paid for it exactly and so that that's
an indicate that tells us right there
that you know your income a fifteen
hundred is going to be really really
tough for you guys to make it on and
you're going to end up facing this same
kind of thing again so I think you have
an income crisis more than anything else
and so either Mary case starts making
some real serious Bank or really fast
net profit or you're going to be doing
something else part-time and you're
going to be looking for something new
full-time because your full-time gig
doesn't pay anything and so that's the
stuff you're facing there I think you
can do it we'll walk with you as you
walk through this but it's not you have
a really tough road with the numbers
you're giving me right now so we've got
to change some of these numbers around
that's what it amounts to hold on I'm
gonna have Laura pick up and we're going
to put you through our nine week class
called Financial Peace University
because you honey you need some
financial peace and there's no magic
wands in this class and then you get the
box of stuff there's not a magic wand in
the box it's not gonna make it instantly
easier but it's gonna give you a
detailed system to go with your desire
to get hold of the to get a hold of this
part of your life so that it doesn't get
out of any more out of control and that
that's what you're facing there so good
question thank you for for joining us
and don't keep the house make sure that
the house is sold you cannot afford this
house you are moving and you've got to
find an inexpensive place to live
once the divorce is final and stay as
long as you can stay but in terms of
don't keep it too
don't keep it too try to solidify the
the emotional situation that you're in
that'll get you into a mess a lot of
Mom's do that that becomes single moms
they're trying to keep a house they
can't afford and you can't afford this
one I don't even know what it is but I
can tell you can't afford it right now
so hold on Lara will pick up and we'll
get you signed up for Financial Peace
University and we'll try to help you as
you walk through this I'm sorry you're
going through it hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]